Nevada schools receiving an enormous
injection of cash after the governor
signed a historic education budget thank
you for joining us at five I'm Brian
Loftus and I'm Denise Valdez now the
state is also
currently student Behavior passing bills
that will immediately expel students who
bring a gun to the classroom eight news
now education reporter Joshua paguera
joining us in studio and Joshua I
understand this came after some pretty
tense negotiations yeah Brian Denise
it's a deal that was announced by
Republican Governor Joe Lombardo and
Democratic Leadership just after
midnight but the end result is Clark
County Schools I expect to get three
thousand dollars more per year for every
student it represents a quarter increase
to their budget students that are at
risk or English language Learners will
get even more but it's what lawmakers
are doing to address student violence
that may have the biggest impact
ab330 and ab285 are largely similar in
that students as young as 8 years old
can now be expelled if they're caught
with a gun or assault a teacher Marine
nicest president of the Clark County
Education Association says the uptick in
violence has impacted a teacher's
ability to teach and a student's ability
to learn we want to ensure that their
systems in place that not that protect
not only just the educator but the rest
of the classroom and the rest of the
students according to the district is
data school police seized 32 guns and
204 knives during the
2022-2023 school year from the start of
the school year to mid-February CCSD PD
made 94 arrests 30 for battering
assaults 29 arrests for fights and 23
for harassment and threats student has a
behavior problem that needs to be
addressed whether it's through mental
health professionals like our counselors
or social workers that should be put in
place but we also want to ensure that
our Educators and students feel safe
lawmakers passed in 2019 a restorative
Justice law that requires schools to
adopt certain interventions such as
making students write an apology letter
as a form of discipline rather than
suspension or expulsion while pushback
began among teachers the year kids
returned to the classroom in 2021 which
led to a spike in violent incidents
Governor Joe Lombardo said during his
State of the State address he wanted to
change the restorative justice law while
well intended this law has led to
instances of disruptive and dangerous
situations in schools across the state
now this Law requires schools to report
before August 1st several key data
points including the ratio of students
to school counselors now in a statement
on these bills CCSD superintendent Dr
Jesus Jarvis says in part These funds
will advance K-12 education in Clark
County by providing students with the
resources they need and funding
competitive wages for our employees We
join with Nevada's leadership United in
our focus on accountable outcomes across
the education effort
Joshua thanks for that so it's been a
last-minute push to try and get all this
stuff done there is another education
bill that's the school choice bill that
Governor Lombardo is really pushing for
but it has yet to even receive a vote
but did get a hearing today as part of
the deal that was struck last night